we have Maurice Ashley with a special
guest it's me with Daphne
Dorsey corporate media relations manager
for Monsanto Daphne I know you a little
bit under the weather but we appreciate
that you braved it here to join us tell
us why it's so important for Monsanto to
be sponsoring chess programming
well Monsanto is Monsanto and it's
philanthropic arm the Monsanto fund
supports STEM related activities and
programs and so some of the activities
that the Chess Club of st. Louis does
with rural schools as well as the st.
Louis Public Schools are stem focused
when you play chess you have to use your
strategic thinking you have to think
about your planning your moves and these
are all learning tools that are
associated with stem and so that's one
of the main reasons why we support this
program and others like it we see images
of these beautiful faces have you had a
chance to see some of the kids that
you're programming has affected yes I
have I have and it's great because not
only are they learn not only only are
they learning how to play an exciting
game but again they're using the skills
that they're acquiring not only in their
academic life at school but also as they
progress an age and in their college
years and also in their professional
lives too is there any Monsanto chess
club out there that you guys have not
that I'm aware of but we have a lot of
employees that do play chess I know that
there's some big news going on around
Monsanto I think there's a bear
relationship buyout or something going
on well there is a merger that's
underway however both companies are
still separate there is not been
anything official we are still operating
it's two separate companies we're
waiting on regulatory approvals from the
Department of Justice as well as from
other regulatory agencies in other
countries and so bear is sort of
spearheading that process okay so that's
big news I'm sure but we want to know is
both sides are gonna double their
funding for the Chess Club well I do
know that over the past several years
we've given approximately $70,000 to the
st. Louis chess club and I know that
there's a grant for 25,000 that's
awaiting approval from our Monsanto fund
board and so again this is a pro
that we support that we love and enjoy
and because not only does it benefit the
things that you all are doing but it's
also encouraging young people to get
involved in a great sport so we
appreciate that and we appreciate your
braving your illness and coming out
looking resplendent thank you so much
that the for joining us Daphne doors
making we're a corporate relations
manager for Monsanto doing great work as
a partner to the Chess Club Thank You
Daphne and Thank You Monsanto wonderful
to have all your support